un cargo battant pavillon cambodgien a
été arraisonné par la marine française à
son bord plus d'une tonne et demie de
cocaïne
la grèce a arrêté les deux propriétaires
du navire ce vendredi planches elle les
460 élèves de première sur l'épreuve de
français qui comptera pour le pack 2003
avec comme nouveauté un sujet de la
mention les 460 mille élèves après
l'effondrement des bleus au mondial
roger lemerre obtient un sursis la
fédération française de football se
donne jusqu'au 6 juillet prochain
démissionnera démissionnera pas et puis
un chinois sous la coupole françois
cheng et le premier écrivain asiatiques
à devenir académicien jacques chirac
salue le philosophe le poète le
calligraphe de renom à sage pour notre
temps voilà monsieur bonsoir c'est vers
le port de brest que le navire
arraisonné au large des côtes d'afrique
fait route
il devrait rejoindre la france d'ici
quelques jours à joli coup de filet de
la police internationale puisque au
moment où la marine française lançait
son opération en pleine mer les cerveaux
de ce trafic de cocaïne n'était arrêtée
hier soir en grèce mais d'abord retour
sur les événements qui ont contraint le
cargo à s'arrêter dans les eaux
internationales une partie de la cocaïne
a été jeté par dessus bord mathias
hillion
l'opération est exceptionnel et
périlleuse
l'abordage du cargo cambodgien vient de
commencer
ces images sont tournées par une caméra
infrarouge embarquée à bord d'un avion
de la marine nationale
en quelques minutes la trentaine de
commandos marins prend possession du
winner à bord du navire de la cocaïne 2
tonnes au minimum l'opération est
réussie
après des débuts difficiles quand ce
navire de la marine nationale l'aviso
commandant bouan décide d'arraisonner le
cargo le capitaine du winner fait la
sourde oreille
pas plus de réponse après deux coups de
semonce c'est à matignon qui est
finalement prise la décision de faire
feu sur le navire qui obtempère après
une nouvelle menace des militaires
français
l'aviso a dit si vous ne répondez pas si
vous ne stopper pas je vais tirer dans
votre gouvernail et là il a répondu
immédiatement l'argent à quelques milles
des îles canaries
c'est l'aboutissement d'une enquête
internationale la france la grèce
l'espagne et les états unis y ont
collaboré
les spécialistes des trafics de drogue
salue la réussite de l'opération
mais relativise cette prise c'est une
bonne opération c'est une saisie
intéressante mais pas exceptionnel il y
en a des dizaines par an les espagnols
il ya dix ans izzy 10 tonnes donc toute
la mise en scène qui l'entourent paraît
un peu disproportionné évidemment on ne
peut pas s'empêcher de savoir qu' il y à
dimanche des élections
le cargo est attendu à brest dans huit
jours pour une fouille total de ses
cales autre plaque tournante de
l'acheminement de la drogue mais cette
fois ci vers l'europe les antilles qui
servent de porte d'entrée aux
trafiquants ces dernières années la
surveillance de cette région a été
renforcée mais bien difficile de pouvoir
contrôler chaque navire chaque bateau de
plaisance susceptibles de transporter
des stupéfiants
loïc de la mornais juillet 1998 au large
des côtes vénézuéliennes pour la
première fois des policiers du raid
assisté par la marine nationale
interviennent conjointement sur un
bateau suspect l'enquète a duré deux ans
elle aboutira au démantèlement d'un
réseau et à l'arrestation de 16
personnes
trois ans plus tard jour pour jour cette
fois ci au large de la guyane la marine
nationale arraisonnent un bateau de
pêche suspects en plusieurs jours
il n'a ajouté aucun filet à l'eau à son
bord douaniers et gendarmes découvriront
un peu moins de deux tonnes de cocaïne
pure à l'époque cela représente un
montant de 10 milliards de francs
l'équivalent de 30 airbus pour les
trafiquants le chapelet d'îles des
antilles est une aubaine la région est
difficilement contrôlable
ainsi en guadeloupe ces bateaux saisis
avec de la drogue à leur bord montre
bien l'ampleur du trafic mais la tâche
des douaniers français est ardue s'il
vous plaît dans cette zone de forte
navigation commerciale difficile de
surveiller chaque bateau chaque creek ya
tellement de points possibles de passage
venait que ce soit gardé 24 heures sur
il faudrait qu'on soit 2000 douaniers
sur toutes les plages là c'est pas
possible
ce soir là les douaniers ont encore fait
chou blanc si la mer des caraïbes est
l'une des principales routes
d'exportation de la drogue
c'est en raison de sa proximité avec le
premier pays producteur de cocaïne
la colombie d'où proviennent 70 % des
800 à 1000 tonnes de cocaïne produites
chaque année dans le monde
la moitié de la drogue par vers les
états unis
l'autre moitié est destinée aux marchés
européens dont l'espagne est la première
porte d'entrée
aujourd'hui la crainte du sida à
détourner les consommateurs européens de
l'héroïne au profit de la cocaïne en
pleine explosion sur le vieux continent
après la série de braquage en plein jour
ces derniers mois paris opération nous
police en seine sané dans une cité hlm
pas d'interpellation mais un certain
nombre d'indicés serait en cours
d'analysé parallèlement à cette affaire
ce sont deux jeunes qui s'apprêtait à
attaquer un bureau de change dans la
capitale qui ont été arrêtés avant de
passer à l'acte christelle bertrand
début d'après midi
le déploiement policier et ciblée
organisé au pied d'un immeuble de la
cité du franc moisin à saint denis
la police s'intéresse aux contenus d'un
box dans le parking souterrain à
l'intérieur elle va saisir trois
scooters et de motos vraisemblablement
impliqué dans différents braquages
l'une d'entre elles pourrait avoir servi
il ya deux jours dans le hold up de la
place saint augustin dans le viiie
arrondissement 4 masqué ont brisé les
vitrines de cette bijouterie à coups de
masse et se sont emparés des bijoux
avant de prendre la fuite en moto la
police
lancés à leur poursuite avait perdu leur
trace à hauteur de stains en seine saint
denis depuis le début de l'année les
attaques de bijouteries sont en forte
hausse
les enquêteurs ont noté des similitudes
dans le mode opératoire de plusieurs
braquages et quand l'hélicoptère de la
police a pu suivre les malfaiteurs ils
ont réussi à s'évaporer aux abords des
cités de la banlieue nord de paris
les suites judiciaires de l'explosion de
l'usiné azf à toulouse le directeur et
huit de ses collaborateurs ont été mises
en examen cet après-midi après 24 heures
de garde à vue
zine dine boudaoud juliette marin
ces trois chefs d'atelier qui te libre
le tribunal de toulouse
ils font partie des neuf cadres d'azf
mise en examen pour homicide
involontaire
serge biechelin le directeur de l' usine
à tromper la vigilance des journalistes
conseillé par ses avocats il adopter
dans le bureau des juges la même
stratégie que face aux policiers le
silence un silence extrêmement parlant a
commenté le procureur de la république
agacé l'entreprise l'a dit publiquement
elle estime que les investigations qui
ont été menées jusqu'ici ne sont pas les
bonnes
moi j'estime que je suis pas de faute
personnellement tout à fait de cet avis
mais c'est le tribunal qui tranchera
s'il affaire va devant un tribunal sans
relâche depuis trois jours les salariés
d'azf soutiennent leurs dirigeants
aujourd'hui c'est au tribunal qu'il
conteste comme leur patron l'action de
la justice
la stratégie cela consiste à mettre les
gens en garde à vue parce que comme ça
c'est déjà bon symptômes pour bien
montrer aux gens que si on les met en
garde à vue quand même c'est qu'à
quelque chose bon et la halle c'est ça
la stratégie judiciaire les magistrats
instructeurs pourrait maintenant
s'intéresser à la tête du groupe total
fina elf que nos dépends l'usiné azf
revenons à présent sur le tueur en série
patrice alègre à nouveau dossier qui
concerne le meurtre d'une jeune fille
est actuellement entre les mains du juge
chargé de l'affairé alègre france
wauquiez valérie était très vite une
fille dynamique tout le monde l'adoré ce
coupé est apprécié de tout le monde
karachi
valérie 16 ans disparaît en août 1990 un
jour de fête foraine à saint jory près
de toulouse son corps est retrouvé dix
jours plus tard au bord de la garonne
dissimuler sous des branchages et un
pneu de tracteur l'autopsié ne permet
pas d'élucider les causes de la mort un
forain puis le propre père de valérie
sont soupçonnés avant d'être mis hors de
cause
l'enquète s'enlise le dossier est
clôturée mais à l'époque on ignore qu'un
tueur en série patrice alègre sévit dans
la région
depuis allègre le prédateur a été
condamné à perpétuité pour cinq meurtres
et un viol mais les gendarmes le
soupçonne dans une vingtaine d'autres
affaires et ils reprennent toutes les
enquêtes à 0 fait troublant
patrice alègre se rendait régulièrement
à saint jory à l'époque de la mort de
valérie police et les enquêteurs faire
leur boulot correctement tranquillement
savard nc à petits pas je le sais je
hier la fille ne reviendra pas ça fait
12 ans mais il faut kolinka travail
patrice alègre et déjà mises en examen
dans cinq autres affaires de meurtres et
de viols
il devrait de nouveau passé devant une
cour d'assises durant le premier
semestre 2003 ce vendredi les élèves de
1re plancher sur le bac français une
épreuve anticipée pour le bac 2003 qui
comporte une vraie nouveauté que nous
dévoile le claude poznanski et valérie
lucas deux fois les tâches du bac a
commencé ce matin c'est le français
nouvelle épreuve nouvelle angoisse paul
isabelle et sophie
on doit vous même
quatre heures d'épreuves au choix trois
sujets un commentaire d'un texte de
voltaire une dissertation et la
nouveauté un dialogue de théâtre à
inventer à partir d'un texte de
giraudoux la guerre de troie n'aura pas
lieu
c'est enfin fini terminé nouvelle
approche du jeune invention c'est une
bonne idée ce moment ouais c'est la
sortie tôt quand on n'a pas d'idée sur
les deux autres sujets les plus dans le
convoi composé de l'argumentation sait
convaincre et persuader ses réflexions
qui est plus personnel la plupart des
élèves rencontrés ont choisi ce nouveau
sujet d'invention voilà la guerre donc
il fallait écrire un
nous adapter à frasne entre trois
personnages donc sur la guerre de troie
je pense que dans le sujet d'imagination
ce n'était pas exactement si ça va
plaire aux correcteurs ou pas mais je
suis plutôt positive après les cris il y
aura l'oral dans quelques jours résultat
de l'épreuve lé 10 juillet pour isabelle
et sophie et sans vouloir consoler les
candidats qui échoueraient au bac il
existe de nombreuses filières qui
permettent de poursuivre ses études sans
le diplôme en poche
isabelle quintard daniel leno le bac
c'est parfois ratés mais rien n'est
jamais perdu
entrée par exemple l université par la
grande porte et sans le bac c'est
possible ces quatre étudiants l'ont fait
en s'inscrivant à un diplôme d'accès aux
études universitaires
ledl tamina tri
mon bac abidal est resté ça fait très
mal donc automatiquement
suite à ça après j'ai été cassée pendant
un petit bout de temps j'ai j'ai
découvert quelque chose en musique si
j'ai continué là dedans et j'ai
découvert qui a raison c'est d'avoir
l'équivalent du bac pour ma revanche on
va dire j'ai tout arrêté en fait à
l'entrée du lycée j'ai commencé à
travailler en fait tu commencé à faire
pas mal de petits boulots
donc c'est vrai que là dessus c'est une
deuxième chance il faut attendre deux
ans après l'examen pour y prétendre et
justifiez de 2 années d'activité
professionnelle
autre alternative pour intégrer la
faculté la capacité en droit ou en
gestion si vous préférez une formation
professionnelle vous pouvez choisir
l'alternance avec des contrats de
qualification ou d'apprentissage
autre solution s'inscrire dans une école
privée ou bien encore tenter les
concours de la fonction publique
on le voit la route menant à son futur
métier n'est jamais barry bien se mettre
dans la tête que le fait de ne pas avoir
le bac à condition qu'on les assume et
c'est ça le vrai problème permet
d'ouvrir des carrières sauf qu'après il
va falloir penser à faire de la
formation continue et à continuer à
étudier non plus à 20 ans mais à 25 à 30
à 35
et puis bien sûr le meilleur conseil à
donner reste de retenter la fameuse
épreuve
90% des redoublants sont couronnés de
succès mauvaise semaine pour la bourse
de paris avec un nouveau bilan la baisse
4 4% sur la semaine les valeurs
technologiques sont très secoués
le cac40 est dessus est descendu en
dessous de la barre des 3900 points
aujourd'hui
il a terminé sur une nouvelle baisse de
9% un niveau proche de l'après 11
septembre le porte monnaie électronique
ne fait pas encore l'unanimité il est
vrai qu'il n'était c'est que dans
quelques départements mais son
utilisation sera généralisée d'ici la
fin de l'année prochaine ce dispositif
permet de s'acquitter s'emmenait et par
carte de petites sommes explications des
guides par payer sa baguette avec une
carte rechargeable
c'est maintenant possible dans certaines
régions grâce à monnet se porte monnaie
électronique est fournie par les banques
et vous permet de vous passer
complètement de ces pièces en centimes
d'euro si compliqué et pour moi ça c'est
le côté pratique
en revanche les commerçants sont
beaucoup moins ravi comme pour les
paiements en carte bleue
ils doivent reverser leurs ventes une
petite commission sur chaque transaction
réalisée avec moneo pour le commerçant
déjà il ya des frais
je pense moi j'ai pas pris au début
après le client et pas déçu toujours un
petit mot n'est bon résultat les débuts
du porte monnaie électronique sont
difficiles il faut dire que seules les
zones en jaune sur cette carte sont
équipés la moitié de la france pourra
payer avec moneo fin 2002 l'ensemble du
territoire sera prêt en 2003 selon
l'entreprise qui orchestre le
développement de moneo le porte-monnaie
électronique devrait s'imposer dans les
habitudes des français
il ya un début à tout la carte bancaire
elle a mis dix ans avant d'être vraiment
généralement utilisés c'est un nouveau
moyen de paiement est ce que nous voyons
c'est que l'utilisation croisent chaque
jour les pièces en euros à peine arrivée
pourrait donc un jour disparaître des
comptoirs dernier jour de campagne avant
le deuxième tour des législatives
l'occasion d'abord de faire les comptes
à proprement parler chaque voix des
électeurs et chaque député lui
constituera le trésor de guerre de
chacun des partis le compte est loin
d'être bon pour le parti communiste qui
n'a pas su trouver un écho suffisant
auprès des électeurs d'autres comme ump
en revanche vont toucher un pactole et
les nuques plus les bulletins sans fil
plus les caisses des formations
politiques se remplissent une voie pour
un candidat c'est un euro 66 pour le
parti qu'il représente
de plus chaque élu lui rapporte 45000
euros par an grand vainqueur dans les
urnes
l'ump fait fortune huit millions et demi
de voix entre 392 et 427 élus selon les
estimations le parti chiraquien devrait
toucher chaque année 33 millions d'euros
dette publique
moitié moins pour le parti socialiste
s'il perd comme annoncé la moitié de ses
élus il devra se contenter chaque année
de 16 millions d'euros 8 de moins que
pendant la dernière législation loin
derrière les autres formations
politiques
malgré ses 11 % voix le front national
aura peu ou pas d'élu il touchera 4
millions huit cent mille euros en
grosses difficultés l'udf qui perd des
élus au profit de l'ump
du même coup son financement annuel est
dit
c'est par cinq il passe à 3 millions
d'euros un plan de licenciement est à
l'ordre du jour tout comme au parti
communiste déjà ruinée par l'élection
présidentielle le pc devrait l'être
encore parler législatif il pourrait ne
toucher désormais que deux millions
d'euros contre 6 auparavant
à gauche seuls les verts pourraient
tirer leur épingle du jeu et voir
augmenté légèrement leur dotation le nom
à paris où quelques duels s'annoncent
plutôt serré au point que des
personnalités politiques sont venus
prêter main-forte candidats sur le pavé
jean pierre raffarin ou bernadette
chirac d'un côté de l'autre le maire de
la capitale où dominique strauss kahn
paris devenue une estrade politique ces
derniers jours avec et ces points chauds
lorrain qui mme mathias barrois au top
50 des plus beaux parrainage jean
françois legaret décroche sans aucun
doute le disque d'or ce soir là le
candidat ump de la première
circonscription a fait venir à sa droite
le ministre de la culture jean-jacques
aillagon le chanteur jean-luc lahaye et
tous les amis de jean tiberi
et des invités est le plus à même de
vous faire gagner
jean luc lahaye ou jean jacques aillagon
à bastille pour tous avec nous je crois
que ça se travaille
le résultat sera vraiment très bon vous
voulez me rendre jaloux non mais
l'invité vedette de jean françois
legaret c'est bernadette chirac qui une
fois de plus vient soutenir un candidat
en difficulté en difficulté car si à
gauche la tribune semble un peu fatigué
le maire de paris lui est remonté à bloc
il est venu soutenir martine billard qui
menacent de faire basculer la première
circonscription dans la 11e
yves cochet a déplacé dsk mais il doit
le partager avec serge blisko candidat
dans la circonscription voisine
convoité par jacques toubon vous fait
carrément de d'un coup c'est un procédé
industriel maintenant là mais étaient
côte à côte face à yves cochet la
secrétaire d'état dominique versini a
fait venir son patron jean pierre
raffarin qui n'a pas du tout l'intention
de la laisser partir pour l'assemblée je
souhaite pouvoir continuer à travailler
avec m bien sûr dans le nord de paris la
gauche est également menaçante alors
nicolas sarkozy vient haranguer les
foules pour défendre la candidature de
patrick stefanini le risque principal
c'est quoi c'est que cette
circonscription sorte de la république
le risque principal à gauche il est tout
autre c'est qu'annick le petit déjà
maire du 18e rate la circonscription qui
va avec
bertrand delanoë est donc venu en
renfort franchement je souhaite que vous
et lisier des députés ned qui me pousse
et puis il ya encore la 15e
circonscription où la primaire à droite
n'en finit pas d'un côté laurent
dominati parachuté par l'ump
pour françois fillon ça tombe bien le
suppléant c'est son chef de cabinet le
ministre est donc venu lui-même signer
les autographes pour le candidat en face
gilbert gantier député sortant qui ne
veut pas lâcher son fauteuil
françois bayrou est venu lui dire qu'il
avait raison de faire de la résistance
ici la gauche a été mise hors jours
premier tour la circonscription n'est
menacée par rien que par un duel
d'ambitions personnelles
gros plan à présent sur nanterre où la
tragédie qui a touché le haut conseil
municipal ne semble avoir aucune
incidence sur le choix des électeurs
assez la maire communiste jacqueline
fraysse est en position délicate
nathalie moisan pétrissez cher pas
d'autographe devenue malgré elle une
vedette médiatique après la tuerie dans
son conseil municipal
madame le maire a gardé sa modestie
député pendant 13 ans maire depuis dix
sept ans jette une phrase tente de
garder l'un des derniers bastions
communistes et fait campagne dans ces
cités qui cumule les problèmes à
commencer par celui du logement ya 2200
panique s'en ficher qui attend il ya des
tas de gens qui sont hébergés ça c'est
pas ma faute
après une visite dans les très grands
verres logement
là j'y peux rien l'émotion suscitée par
la tuerie de nanterre n'a pas favorisé
la députée sortante elle n'est arrivée
qu'en seconde position dimanche
nous avons eu des témoignages de
sympathie très fort de la part de tous
et nous y avons été extrêmement sensible
en même temps bien entendu les
événements tragiques de nanterre n'ont
pas transformé les personnes qui votent
rpr en électeurs communistes et
christian dupuy candidat de l'ump est
lui aussi souvent interpellé sur le
drame des partis comme un diable il a
sauté par la fenêtre des policiers ont
essayé de l'attrapper centre pour autant
il fait campagne sur les thèmes
nationaux de la droite l'emploi et
l'insécurité
tout le monde a été profondément affecté
par cette affaire là et cette campagne a
été d'une certaine façon
le moyen à travers le débat démocratique
chacun défendant ses convictions
d'exorciser d'une certaine manière le
drame
et peut-être que le débat a gagné en
dignité en respect comme pour marquer le
retour à la normale nanterre inscrit
cette élection dans la vague nationale
et voilà la députée sortante de gauche
menacé comme en 93 a marseille le
chauffeur de bus qui avait affirmé avoir
été agressé par des jeunes qui voulaient
le brûler vif comparaissait aujourd'hui
nous avions nous-mêmes donné quoi cette
affaire qui avait indigné les syndicats
mais tout n'était que pure invention
l'homme est un affabulateur le chauffeur
d'après son avocat présente des troubles
psychologiques yannick à rossi penin
jour dans un grand gaillard plus d'un
mètre 90 il a pratiqué des sports de
combat a été agent de sécurité avant son
éphémère carrière de chauffeur de bus
pourtant christophe bengo a dit qu'il
avait peur derrière son volant
agoraphobie le 23 mars dernier il aurait
paniqué et pour changer d'affectation
mise en scène une rocambolesque histoire
l' affaire fait grand bruit deux hommes
masqués arrose le chauffeur d'essence
lui mettent le feu
mais tout ça n'est que mise en scène
préméditée depuis plusieurs jours par
christophe qui ne supporte plus de
travailler sur une ligne difficile
psychologique qui était désespéré parce
qu'il a connu une enfance
amoureuse et c'est sûrement une des
raisons pour lesquelles il a commis cet
acte
un acte qui avait provoqué une journée
de grève par solidarité à la rtnc
transformer en journée de trahison selon
la régie des transports marseillais qui
demandent le remboursement d'une journée
de perte d'exploitation
il est rare effectivement qu'un
mouvement aussi important qu'ils
puissent se passer dans une ville comme
marseille soit pris en considération par
un tribunal qui nous permet de
poursuivre le responsable du préjudice
subi christophe benoit est condamné à 18
mois de prison avec sursis
il pourra donc continuer à exercer sa
nouvelle activité de chauffeur livreur
tout en poursuivant une psychothérapie
le tribunal a assorti la peine d'une
obligation de soin aux états unis
zacarias moussaoui qui sera jugé pour
son éventuelle implication dans les
attentats du 11 septembre vient
d'obtenir l'autorisation d'être son
propre avocat
le français qui y gagnent cause risquent
la peine de mort et l énarque les
avocats commis d'office moussaoui les
récuse parce que dit-il ils font partie
du complot contre moi de sa mère venue à
nouveau de france pour le convaincre
qu'elle peut l'aider il dit qu'elle aime
certes mais qu'elle ne parle pas anglais
après une heure et demie d'audience hier
soir devant le tribunal de virginie qui
le jugera en octobre zacarias moussaoui
a obtenu ce qu'il cherchait il est
mentalement apte à se défendre lui même
et la juge n'a d'autre choix que de lui
accorder ce droit
un comportement jugé suicidaire parce
qu'ils ont tenté jusqu'ici de le
défendre et de lui éviter la peine
capitale
nous pensons que c'est un désert c'est
impossible qu'il ait un procès équitable
ans représentant lui-même il ya besoin
d'un avocat
la juge veut s'assurer qu'il comprend ce
qui l'attend en tant qu'accusé il n'aura
pas accès à certaines pièces du dossier
de sa prison de haute sécurité
il ne pourra même pas rencontré tous les
témoins et n'est pas autorisée à
téléphone ou sa wii est calme il parle
bien l'anglais et reste déterminée la
vie m'est donnée par dieu elle est bien
trop précieuse je ne vais pas jouer avec
lens moussaoui à la juge
c'est pourtant exactement ce qu'il vient
de faire en récusant ses avocats commis
d'office des spécialistes de la peine
capitale
désormais moussaoui est seul seul contre
tous ce nouvel attentat au pakistan
cette fois ci c'est une voiture piégée
qui a explosé à karachi
devant le consulat américain onze
personnes ont été tuées aucun américain
des dizaines de personnes ont été
blessées les etats unis ont annoncé
qu'ils fermaient leur mission
diplomatique au pakistan et puis il ya
quelques instants un groupe jusqu'alors
inconnu a revendiqué cet attentat il
s'agit du quatrième acte terroriste dont
celui qui a touché les français depuis
le début de l'année dans ce pays contre
les occidentaux nouveaux massacres en
algérie onze personnes ont été tuées
hier soir au sud d'alger par un groupe
armé depuis le début de ce mois ce ne
sont pas moins de 45 personnes qui ont
été assassinées le reste de l'actualité
en france avec au plan médical les
premières tentatives d'une europe
sanitaires à la frontière
franco-espagnole la cerdagne est une
région montagneuses enclavées du coup
les patients français sont autorisés à
aller se soigner au plus près c'est à
dire de l'autre côté de la frontière en
espagne mais uniquement pour les
urgences et les soins sont remboursés
comme ici karine tomasi parce qu'elles
pensent même et un bébé en avance sur
son temps un mois avant l'accouchement
prévu à perpignan sa maman a dû se
replier en pleine nuit sur l'hôpital le
plus proche celui de puits cerda ville
voisine mais espagnol mon mari a eu peur
surtout prend la route pour la perpignan
vous les virages et tout ça il ya une
heure de route à et donc il m'a dit je
préfère qu'on a pu certains disaient que
c'était ça le connais tu es mal
accueillis tout ça et moi je connaissais
pas du tout elle est alors je suis ravi
car la jeune maman a été la première
frontalière à ne pas avoir eu besoin
d'avancer les frais de son
hospitalisation soit 7000 euros
la convention signée entre l'hôpital
depuis cerda et celui de perpignan ne
concerne encore que les urgences mais
c'est un premier pas qui pourrait à
terme faciliter l'accès aux soins des
15000 habitants de la sardane française
privée d'hôpital de proximité
ce que nous essayons d'abord c'est de
les patients qu'on a les avoir dans les
meilleures conditions pour nous pour un
fait pour elle sur ton et d'étapes et
établir une relation de confiance entre
la population française est chez nous on
voit ce qu'il ya de plus en plus dans
les patients français ont pu imaginer un
hôpital européen véritable européen
européens vont travailler des médecins
français espagnol et peut-être d'autres
médecins d'autres nationalités
en attendant l'hôpital transfrontalier
ce sont ces bébés qui avec leur double
nationalité dans nos vies à l'europe de
la santé au moment où l'on parle du
baccalauréat et des prochaines
inscriptions à l'université les sourds
et malentendants utilise pour
communiquer la langue des signes
mais cette fameuse langue ne possède
essentiellement que des mots du
quotidien et pour être mieux adaptés aux
besoins des étudiants un site internet a
mis en place un dictionnaire tout en
images avec l'apparition nécessaire de
nouveaux mots laetitia phuc dsq renier
pascal a toutes les qualités d'un très
bon élève il lui manque juste les
oreilles pour entendre ses professeurs
dans sa classe une interprète vient
souvent de soutenir ali traduit en
langue des signes
les cours et des exercices pascal peut
ainsi enfin suivre les grandes lignes on
s'en rend compte
en dehors des coûts en communique par
mail pour donner les compléments
d'information parce que qu'ils
n'arrivent pas à acquérir la totalité
des informations c'est pas possible
pascal est étudiant en iut de génie
civil avec son interprète il a été
obligé d'inventer des signes parce que
le jargon technique qui l'utilisent tous
les jours
il n'existe pas encore dans cette langue
pour cent moi je disais béton armé
l'interprète voilà il traduisait béton
armé comme armés de militaires quoi
alors ça c'était c'était une convention
qu'on avait trouvé entre nous mais enfin
le geste c'était faux une équipe de
souris d'antan donc ébauche justement un
tout nouveau dictionnaire des signes
tout en image et sur internet chaque
jour une traduisent de nouveaux mots
comme par exemple échographe si demain
un internaute me propose un signe par
dessin vidéo n'importe quoi un autre
signe pour évoquer l'échographie on va
le mettre aussi sur le site et c'est
celui qui sera le plus utilisé qui
restera internet média favori des sourds
car très accessible permet une large
diffusion de ce dictionnaire bientôt 700
mo seront en ligne en un outil essentiel
pour tous les sourds qui souhaitent
sortir de l' isolement
parmi les titres de l'actualité de ce
vendredi après le cuisant échec des
bleus on retiendra bien sûr le sursis
accordé à roger lemerre la fédération
française de football reporte sa
décision au 6 juillet prochain reste à
l'appréciation et à la conscience du
sélectionneur de l'équipe de france de
démissionner ou de ne pas démissionner
nathanaël de rincquesen nadine picard
guillaume pautrat
rien de tel qu'une petite promenade à
l'ombre des platanes de l'avenue d'iéna
pour se changer les idées
avant une journée qui s'annonce agitée à
dimanche et ponctuelles roger lemerre se
présente au siège de sa fédération pour
une réunion concernant son avenir
chronique d'une démission annoncée deux
heures plus tard coup de théâtre à la
surprise générale
roger lemerre fait son apparition dans
la salle réservée aux conférences de
presse il ne sourit pas il ne parle pas
mais il est toujours le sélectionneur
national
le sélectionneur national n'a pas
proposé sa démission
le sélectionneur national a bien compris
qu'il était maître de son destin et le
sélectionneur national m'a dit qu'il me
ferait savoir en temps utile je crois ne
pas trahir les paroles de roger lemerre
quelle serait sa motivation à l'égard de
la fédération et bien sûr de son
président
le sélectionneur national a jusqu'au 5
juillet 2002 pour faire connaître sa
position
en attendant roger lemerre sont étalés
sans un mot mais visiblement ravi du
drôle de tour joué à tous ceux qui le
voyaient déjà démissionné et maintenant
le football en fait avec pour les deux
pays qui accueille le mondial
une victoire historique pour la première
fois la corée du sud et le japon se
qualifie de la joie à leforest chien est
riche en un océan rouge une vague de
bonheur
les sud coréens vibre à l'unisson libre
à domicile cette ferveur comme parfois
seul le sport peut en offrir se décline
dans le stade
autant que dans les villes un million de
personnes dans les rues de séoul dernier
match du premier tour les portugais bon
de voir que du rouge en toute logique
joão pinto et expulsé dès la 27e minute
béton le sera un peu plus tard à 11 ça
n'était déjà pas facile à neuf la tâche
portugaise par est irréalisable
71e minute j son parc fait son show que
tu pensais les sud-coréens physique mais
limitée techniquement auront sans doute
admirer la leçon 1 à 0 les supports et 1
et du tout le pays se découvre une
passion pour le ballon rond
les portugais vont bien tenté de revenir
mais comme on dit il ya des jours comme
ça où ça ne fasse pas pour le portugal
c'est l'élimination
les sud coréens terminent premiers de
leur groupe bravo messieurs
au japon dans le stade national de tokyo
personne ne regarde la pluie et pour
cause les yeux tournés vers l'écran on
suit le match japon unies'' et à
distance un but pour maurice shima un
second pour nakata véritablement bravo
messieurs
mille fois bravo d'osaka à tokyo fans au
bord de la crise de nerfs les bleus qui
gagne les bleus qui crie se sont peu ça
valait bien une petite baignade non loin
du stade avec bonne humeur mais sans
maillot sur ce premier mondial en a dit
les deux pays organisateurs se qualifie
avec panache et deux semaines après le
début du mondial voici les qualifiés
pour les huitièmes de finale et les
rencontres l'allemagne affrontera le
paraguay le danemark l'angleterre la
suède le sénégal l'espagne l'irlande le
mexique les usa le brésil la belgique le
japon la turquie et la corée du sud
l'italie
le choc des mondes avec la visite de
michael jackson au parlement britannique
cela faisait longtemps qu'une star
internationale n'avait pas visité le
très vénérable le palais de westminster
michael jackson a été accueilli par le
ministre de la justice michael jackson
ii
une oeuvre de bienfaisance pour les
victimes africaines du sida le regard de
william klein le plus le plus
francophile photographe américain sur
paris un voyage dans la capitale
immortalisée par les clichés de cet
artiste qui vit depuis un demi siècle en
france une exposition à la maison
européenne qui durera tout l'été se fige
ouvre vers la rue ce saut quand cet
homme regarde paris c'est de tous les
côtés à la fois william klein
l'américain seniors de la photographie
nous offre une vitesse folle dans sa
ville d'adoption
un paris cosmopolite qui bouge qui
avance et qui contrairement à new york
s'exprime avant tout dans la rue que
j'aime beaucoup le défilé des
manifestations et j'ai souvent
l'impression d'appartenir mêmes idéaux
vieira est bon je n'appartiens pas bon
mais il a quelque chose dans la
solidarité
ici les plus beaux coups et là bon comme
dans le livre gilles mélanger les choses
presque sans queue ni tête
car guindé ou débridés tous les paris se
valent pour klein un peu sorcier est
très admirateur des surréalistes tels un
journaliste plein de livres ses notes
mélangeant les époques associant les
enterrements de traîner ou de tino rossi
à celui de maurice thorez
quant à son hommage à magritte ou son
gainsbourg il les fait s'affronter à
l'explosion de couleurs du paris
métissée d'aujourd'hui
un pari où tout le monde a sa valeur
pour l'objectif de william klein j'ai
vraiment très désolé parce que j'avais
justement le l'impression que tu es
ville ou à rien de se passer du tout
kaléidoscope de gueule et d'émotion qui
finissent par faire de paris une sorte
de capitale du monde un monde selon club
un chinois sous la coupole où
l'extravagant parcours de l'écrivain
françois cheng enfants il a suivi ses
études à nankin il a subi les
bombardements des japonais il a obtenu
une bourse à paris où il y vivra des
années de galère son pays d'adoption lui
rend hommage la langue française est
désormais la sienne
il est le premier asiatique à rejoindre
l'académie française geneviève moll
champ du moulin va siéger sous la
coupole avec les tropes votre
représentant de l'esprit français
françois cheng le frêle asiat de 73 et
calligraphe poète et romancier est un
passeur de culture entre la chine et la
france parce que j'ai un innocent j'ai
traversé le destin avec cette innocence
et en même temps cette passion je pense
que c'est ça qui m'a amené là où je suis
aujourd'hui
car à bateaux en 1949 il fut la chine
qui sort de la guerre pour entrer dans
les luttes intestines et choisit la
france et paris à paris place est
marquée par l'occupation là pendant dix
ans tout en faisant ses études il vit de
petits boulots mais il surmonte toutes
les souffrances et s'adonne à sa passion
la culture et surtout la langue
française à travers cette langue kg
vraiment éprouver l'impression de
renommer des choses à neuf comme au
matin du monde comme julie ti il a ciblé
le 2 mai les choses qu'en 1998 et dames
du femina le consacre pour son roman le
dit de tiani une oeuvre encore rattachée
à la chine
je pense que tout en quart temps 7 armes
chinoises dont vous parlez je pense que
je suis quand même à ma manière
enfin
devenu un authentique français
et quel français puisque le prestigieux
aréopage l'accueil aujourd'hui en son
sein les français sont tous des
jardiniers dans l'âme 69% d'entre nous
ça donne à ce loisir qui est souvent une
passion balade de cette femme journal
l'art du jardin avec une tendance
l'exotisme dans le parc de saint cloud
et les norgay frédéric faure oiseaux de
paradis
c'est petit mais n'a rien frileux pour
le contrer il faut dire que dans leur
éden à eux l'afrique du sud
ces végétaux ne connaissent pas le gel
mais comme la passiflore ou encore le
bananier les plantes exotiques se sont
acclimatés à condition de les protéger
pendant l'hiver mandariniers des
citronniers apparaîtrait ainsi dans les
jardins les plus au nord de la france
sur la grume on a une vie permanente à
s'accroît en le taillant le fait pousser
dans l'oeuf et fleurie et en fait on a
un fric et les régions là la récompense
de l'entretien oui l'engouement pour les
plantes venues d'ailleurs n'est pas
récent depuis le 17e siècle
les voyageurs ont rapporté nombre
d'espèces aujourd'hui bien intégré la
tomate
le géranium de nos balcons fascinant
d'origine l'afrique
mais aujourd'hui la mode est asiatique
jacinthe d'eau et grasse et naomi
présent bon vous envahissant ces espèces
importées disent que tu aimes de
modifier notre environnement
je ne crois pas qu'il y ait un réel
risque d'invasion dans les jardins car
toutes les plantes qui craignent le
froid donc qui ont besoin du jardinier
de son aide pendant tout l'hiver
elles ne pourront jamais vivre toute
seule par contre les plantes qui résiste
au froid qui viennent de chine par
exemple du japon qui sont des exotiques
comme l'arbre papillon qui viennent
d'amérique aussi là sont beaucoup plus
dangereuses car elles sont saines tout
seul pour l'instant aucune menace
sérieuse à signaler la radio des
bouquins vieillit n'est pas pour demain
et puis cet hommage bien mérité à
michèle cotta directrice générale de
france 2 qui achève aujourd'hui son
mandat de trois ans tous ses amis et
collaborateurs de la chaîne se sont
retrouvés autour d'elle cet après midi
ainsi se termine ce journal dans un
instant la bto nathalie rihouet puis le
croire ou de valérie maurice 20h55
nestor burma avec marchands 10h30 le
dernier journal laurence piquet de
master dont le café catherine ceylac que
reçoit l'astrologue elisabeth teissier
quant à moi j'aurai le plaisir de vous
retrouver demain dès 13 heures je vous
remercie de votre attention
excellente fin de soirée sur france 2 et
on se quitte avec ses images de paris
sur mer paris transformée en port de
pêche pour la durée du week-end les
artisans pêcheurs ont remonté la seine
pour permettre aux parisiens de
découvrir les trois pieds de la mer
m